hear me yeah perfect okay cool so yeah
as Vanessa said I'm Carolyn and I work
as a technical writer and a front-end
developer in Berlin and I'm here to talk
to you about humanizing your
documentation and for the sake of this
talk documentation is defined as the
information that describes products to
its users and this can mean anything
from API references to getting started
guides to anything in between so I want
to start off with the single question
why do we even write documentation is it
because our competitors have it or
because someone told us to do it or is
it because we really want the people
using our software to achieve their
goals it should be the latter but mm
that's usually not the case writing
documentation is often afterthought is
something that we just get done but what
if we gave our documentation the same
time and consideration that we do the
features we ship use case driven
documentation derives from the idea of
goal driven documentation both of which
were coined and made popular by Tanner
Blaine in 2006 and it works like this
put your users goals at the focal point
of your Docs instead of just describing
interface elements from left to right
and a common way to illustrate this idea
is a drill so if we approach documenting
this drill the same way that most
document software will end up with
something like this how to adjust the
speed how to change the direction of the
drill how to change the drill bit so now
you know how to operate a drill but you
don't actually know how to accomplish
anything with it and these are known as
reference documentation and their
information oriented they describe the
machinery and they're always or they try
to always be accurate and complete and
while this documentation type of
documentation is certainly necessary it
could definitely use a more nurturing
counterpart so if we reach reshape our
thinking just a bit and think about what
it takes to do the job and not just use
the tool we could end up with something
like this how to drill a hole in a flat
surface whether it's
or metal how to select the right screw
for fastening items how to stir paint
with your drill suddenly the
documentation is helping us achieve our
goals and these guides are goal-oriented
they show you how to solve a specific
problem and they're typically presented
in a series of steps but why is this
approach because successful well to
begin to understand that we need to
think back to that original question why
even write dogs and perhaps more
importantly we need to consider who are
we writing documentation for and the
answer is surprisingly simple humans so
yeah yeah with the development of BOTS
and AI this answer could certainly
change in the next couple years but for
now most software documentation is
written with the idea that humans will
read it and humans need that guidance
that documentation is meant to provide
that's why that these same principles
for the drill can also apply to our
software and we aren't writing
documentation to teach someone how to
work with our software but rather we're
teaching it someone how to achieve their
goals and solve their problems using our
software now let's apply this idea to
something more applicable to our
industry say slack slack is a
cloud-based set of team collaboration
tools and because I know they have a
developer portal and thorough
documentation I crawled their sites for
examples and here's what I found as
expected they have those information and
oriented reference Docs that we talked
about earlier they teach us how to add a
bot user to our slack app programming
those bot users and how to subscribe to
event types with the events API that's
nice but maybe as a first-time slack
user I'm not sure how or why I would
need these features so this is a
screenshot from the exact same site just
a different page notice how they are not
only giving us use cases creating simple
workflows building BOTS but they're also
outlining what we can accomplish you
know creating a simple workflow by
completing
ryouta mating tasks like requests and
approvals or building a bot so we can
talk with our users and it points to
that reference documentation that we saw
in the previous slide and now that we
have an idea of what use case driven
documentation is let's take a look at
the outline so when you develop a use
case you typically start with a goal
then if you're using use case driven
development or something similar the
rest of your workflow should look
something like this you'll define the
functional requirements you'll design
the product and then you'll implement
the feature this is called a structured
requirements approach and with an
approach like this we've already solved
half the problem determining what to
document the thing is is that most what
most documentation is doing is starting
at this implementation phase it's once
you've already finished that feature and
this is ok it works the docs get done
but what a use case driven approach is
suggesting is that we start here at you
probably guessed it the use case and the
beauty of this is that you can design
your documentation simultaneously with
the features that you're developing and
when we use this structured requirements
approach we have an established
framework for defining the problems that
where our software will solve and we
also can articulate how people will
solve these problems with use cases and
then these use cases define exactly what
we should be documenting but there's a
problem with that approach first it
requires a fundamental change in how our
team tackles documentation and that's
not always possible also it sounds more
like this beautiful ideal instead of our
you know immediate reality also those
reference Docs you know the ones that
describe what the software can do those
are why documentation have such a bad
rep in this industry they tend to be dry
and really leave us wanting more
personally I know this feeling all too
well because even if I write technical
content for a living I still have a
pretty unsatisfying relationship with
documentation about this time last year
and after two years of working in tech
as a journalist or a writer I decided to
take the dive and learn to code and I
knew exactly what I wanted to focus on
JavaScript but okay I don't know how you
guys felt while you were learning but it
felt like to me every single day I was
asking myself something like what is
going on in my text editor in my
terminal it didn't matter where I looked
I had no idea what was happening
am I the only one who finds this
confusing because I know there are a lot
of people working in JavaScript and they
seem to be thriving but not me not so
much at the moment and do people
actually enjoy this and will I ever
think that programming things with
JavaScript is fun spoil their I got it
together it's pretty fun now but it felt
like in order to do the interesting
things with JavaScript you needed to
know the advanced features not to
mention all of the frameworks and
toolings it felt impossible to keep up
but the most detrimental part I think of
my learning experience was the
documentation I was finding it was
supposed to be fueling my learning but
it was actually stunting it for the most
part and more often than not I felt
really deflated after reading dogs and
my questions they're still left
unanswered and the thing is I'm not
alone in feeling like this documentation
is one of the largest pain points for
developers just search reading
documentation on Twitter and you'll see
that most of the tweets are same not so
positive and here's some of my favorites
actually that I found just within the
last week
hi I was reading your documentation and
you described this data in two different
ways which is correct
thank you the way it works is third
completely different description
or this one nothing like spending a day
reading a hundred and thirty-seven page
PDF for CMS documentation puts head down
on desk and cries I would cry too and
this is my personal favorite bad
documentation is bad and even after
someone else asked this person if there
were no Docs would it be better she
still said deep thoughts honestly yes
because it would waste less of my time
so people love to hate documentation but
I believe that's also on us the people
who write Docs because it seems like we
hate them right back think about the
term users Laura call bag a designer and
accessibility advocate explains this
well she says I tend to not to not even
refer to people as users I refer to them
just as the people who use things she
explains that this is because when we
say user as a developer we're separating
ourselves we turn the people who use our
products into this far away thing and we
don't necessarily think of them as
someone who is just like us and that's
why as a technical writer at my job I
have needed to constantly remind our
developers or myself even that we are
writing for humans and not just that but
we are writing for humans who don't even
want to be reading what we're writing
because people as been as I mentioned
people don't enjoy reading technical
documentation for the most part people
visit your documentation when they're
frustrated they're already mad they're
frustrated with your software they're
disappointed that they haven't been able
to solve the problem on their own and
they're generally feeling pretty low and
that reality is not awesome especially
if you are someone who puts a lot of
love and care and consideration into
your documentation but being aware of
these negative feelings that your
readers are experiencing is key because
these emotions frame the readers
effective and therefore they should
shape the mood of our Docs so what were
these issues that I had with the
documentation I found well I could put
all of it into three categories
they were disorienting the underlying
structure was difficult to follow and
and in some cases the docks were not
accessible as in I literally couldn't
read them because of the way they were
programmed
they were alienating so some
documentation I read it made me feel
super isolated afterwards there were
words or concepts that were assumed
knowledge difficult syntax and that were
never explained and not to mention the
use of gendered or discriminatory
language and finally they were just
plain confusing and it was clear that
the developers working on these features
I was reading the docs about had a huge
depth of knowledge but it wasn't exactly
translating to me as a first-time or
generally pretty new user so now let's
run through each of these one by one
I'll show you the problems with examples
of what not to do followed by some tools
and role models that can help us do
better and all of the what not to do
examples are come from the software
documentation that's actually live on
the internet but I'm trying not to make
too many enemies during this talk so
I've adapted some of them to go back to
that drill example just to keep it keep
the end of em keep it anonymous so let's
start with disorienting a big part of
that as I mentioned was the poorly
defined structure and how we structure
our documentation is really important
because it shapes that learning journey
for our user and the overall experience
for our readers and if the structure is
not well-defined you lose control of how
people interpret your work here's one of
those not-so-great examples and again
adaptive for the drill um so here's
here's the short story
getting up and running quickly with your
drill one read the documentation to read
the documentation 3 remember that you
were warned twice about reading
documentation like art 1 if I'm in the
getting started guide aren't I already
reading the documentation and it goes on
after this to just list off every
command optional or not that's possible
with this tool and I specifically put a
screenshot because I I can't make this
up I cannot make up that someone just
wrote this and it's particularly bad
because getting started guides or any
sort of introduction err materials are
your first impression to potential users
so how can we combat this a mindful
structure whether it's just in one
particular article or throughout your
entire doc app in development we want to
have a clear and easy to follow
structure and when in doubt especially
for individual articles I would aim for
something like this talk about one
specific feature use that kind of
reference Docs and explain what it
really does go on to explain potential
use cases that people could use this or
the best case scenario for people to use
this and finally offer solutions then
for tooling integrations etc because
then you can kind of guide the reader
into what to go to next and this covers
all of your bases it has those
information oriented reference Docs it
has the goal oriented guides and like I
mentioned it plugs what where they
should go next in their journey the next
big issue is unexpected errors so have
you ever read something that I don't
know says something like just run this
snippet and you're good to go
but then when you run the code you get a
big fat error like unfortunately this is
all too common and when error messages
do come up a lot of times they tend to
look like this we have lost connection
to our server and disabled editing
features please verify that you have
internet access
ok this literally tells me nothing all I
know is that I need to check my
connection but I don't understand why my
editing features are disabled will they
still will my changes still save did the
connection go down is mine is it theirs
I don't know so we should consider and
address common errors whenever we know
them and because this helps reassure
your users that mistakes will happen
errors will happen but it also provides
options for troubleshooting so when
you're writing these error messages try
to explain what happened and why and
then tell the readers what to do next so
here's a better solution for our error
mishap earlier this tells you what
happened the fields are locked why it
happened because of no internet
connection and its implications so that
you won't lose changes it appears you
aren't connected to the Internet at the
moment the fields are temporarily locked
so you won't lose any important changes
here's another example and this is a
screenshot from the Apple 2 basic
programming manual from yes the 1970s it
tackles the nuances of common user
errors quite well and they actually
explain many of the syntax errors before
they even have you start coding and this
example in particular also follows
that's three-step approach it tells us
what happened
you got a beep and the syntax error
message why it happened
you probably press return and what to do
next it literally just says for the time
being ignore this message and that's
perfectly fine when we're formatting
these error alerts I'm in a tutorial
especially Django Girls is a great
resource to reference they do a great
job as scattering these types of notes
throughout the tutorial and the format
is clear so that it enables
it enables them to be informative enough
so if people are having errors they know
what to do not to panic and it they're
not so distracting so if you're not
having these errors it's easy to kind of
brush through them alright that's the
last of the disoriented category so
let's move on to alienating and the
first thing that comes to mind with
alienating is insensitive language and
this one can be tricky because across
nationalities and personalities you know
in sensitive language or phrase wording
or phrasing it can mean a lot of
different things and in this case we're
mostly talking about gendered language
profanity racial slurs or anything that
kind of falls under those lines so some
bad exam or not-so-great examples if the
programmer wishes to uphold invariant he
must satisfy the functions preconditions
as a woman Tech I hate reading
documentation like this because I
already feel pretty ostracized in the
community a lot of times and having
something like this shows me that this
isn't for me or this one in this guide I
will show you three main ways to hide
your [ __ ] first of all profanity is
probably not the way to go and also it
doesn't really tell me what it's doing
and both of these are relatively tame
examples but they show instances of you
know this insensitive language both in
both instances they won't always some
people might find it funny but a lot of
people it won't go over well in your
community so you can think before you
type easier said than done but a good
rule to follow is when documenting code
don't make assumptions or make any
implications about race gender religion
political orientation or really anything
else that isn't relevant to your product
and or you can have a linter do it for
you so this is Alex jeaious and it and
it catches insensitive and polarizing
writing in your markdown files and also
suggest helpful alternatives
you can use it on the command line or as
an integration with atom sublime vs code
and even slack and it's also open source
so if you run into some words that
you're like hey I don't know if I'm cool
with this but they're not catching it
you can feel free to contribute I would
also say you should still have a human
an actual human being read over it
preferably someone who's not from your
same nationality or demographic but it's
a good start so here's that same
sentence from earlier but now Alex
jeaious is helping us catch those words
that might be better left out of our
documentation and on that note of words
not to use don't say simply easily easy
simple just leave it out James Harrison
Fisher actually gave an entire talk at
read the docks London about this very
topic at one point he searched the word
simply on github and he found over 92
million references in documentation on
github and it's just not appropriate for
example simply connect to the HTTP
endpoint at API dot my drill comm and
that was it but so ok but we don't know
how to do this or this one we simply
start parsing an expression and
afterwards if the next token is a colon
and the expression was a simple
identifier node then dot the dot I don't
know about you but this doesn't sound so
simple to me and my solution for this
don't use it and just take the word out
completely because really after fixing
bugs for hours do you really want
someone to say to you like but this was
so easy respect people's time and
people's progress and just find another
way to say it be more specific and
figure out why you think it's simple try
it maybe as an alternative being
comparative so X requires less typing
then why or even better be absolute five
lines of code
the next issue that's alienating is
bloated language or these kind of overly
complicated and robust prose and okay
sip of water before this next one this
approach will work for our specific use
case but we haven't achieved the
objective of truly encapsulating the
behavior in a reusable way now every
time we want the drill position for a
different use case we have to create a
new component ie essentially another
drill with screw that renders something
specifically for that use case that's a
mouthful that's a lie and it's only two
sentences um and it's difficult to read
and difficult to comprehend at least on
the first try so an alternative is to
use plain language we want to choose our
language intentionally when we're
writing documentation and using plain
language is critical for a more
inclusive documentation but it can be
difficult because especially if you went
to university they really try to get
that out of you because plain language
is seen as a negative thing but in
reality it's just allowing more people
to understand and comprehend our work
and again there is an app that can help
you so this is Hemingway editor and it
is a tool to paste your text in and
it'll highlight problematic words or
sentences for you as well as offer
suggestions it's available as a text
editor application a web app and even a
linter and so in the case of the example
that we just had it identified that the
first sentence is hard to read that's
why it's highlighted in yellow the
sentence the second sentence is very
hard to read so it's in red um it
highlights adverbs in blue because
they're not necessary for what we're
trying to say and it also points out
words that could have had a simpler
alternative so in this case objective
and our sentence right now is
grade 12 and we want to get that down
and you want to stay around a maximum of
grade 8 reading level and never worry
about a reading level being too low
because as the amazing
Ashley bishops once said no one has ever
complained about something being too
easy to read and now to the issue of it
being confusing
fortunately out of the three issues this
one is actually the one that comes from
a good place so for instance you're just
in way too deep so when you're working
as a developer it can be difficult to
write documentation because you're so
deep in that product and that specific
feature that you're developing so what
often happens is that while you're
writing documentation you might be
talking writing it as if you're talking
to you yourself or maybe one of your
colleagues but the problem is is that
new users or it really any user B don't
have that same frame of reference that
you do and so any you know unexplained
term or skipped step in a tutorial can
destroy the learning journey for that
reader and really put them off of your
documentation so it's important to keep
in mind that everyone is a beginner at
some point and no matter how intuitive
you think your product is or tool my
beam everyone start some way what I've
found to be effective is that is it's
for you to go through the entire process
from start to finish and talk out loud
while you're doing it or explain the
feature as you're going along and have
another colleague close by preferably
someone who's not working on the same
project take notes about what you are
doing and identify those points that
might be confusing or unclear to others
and another confusing issue that kurz
frequently is that your product isn't a
good fit for the person who's reading it
and that's okay just be transparent so
when you know there's a specific use
case that maybe this tool or integration
doesn't work well with just say so
you'll save people a lot of headaches
and long run and also in your
introduction material it helps to remind
people to double check that this tool is
appropriate for what they're trying to
accomplish
the reason documentation does this quite
well in their converting from Jas page
they emphasize that you should make sure
that reason is fitting your needs and it
also points out that you shouldn't
unnecessarily thrash your colleagues
over other languages and frameworks but
for the record that's always unnecessary
you shouldn't do that so I hope that
I've given you a some a new tool to
implement or maybe some new ways to
update your documentation checklist but
before I get off the stage I want to
leave you with something that I learned
during my time working at contentful and
I believe that it's wise words that are
applicable for anyone writing
documentation so when I read through
content tools style guide something
immediately struck me and at the very
beginning it says we aim for accuracy
and consistency sure this is the case
for most Docs but what really got me is
what came next we also want to aim to be
honest helpful and human honest in that
we communicate the pros and cons of a
solution because in doing so will build
trust helpful because we want our users
to succeed I mean their success is
ultimately our success and we want to be
human we want it to feel familiar and
approachable because after all the
people writing your Docs are human -
thank you
you